le sel [ __ ] au boulot contrôleur
technique ça consiste en quoi exactement
je suis là pour me faire engueuler cette
armoire sont remplies de réclamations
malaucène série de votre incompétence
jusqu'à ce que les clients qui posait
problème renoncé à porter plainte on va
l'office les douze ans pacte et pour les
fêtes et vous descendre avec les temps
durs
c'est peut-être pas la peine d'aller si
loin oui mais non mais si moi je suis
book hémisphères quel est le problème
qui vous amène possible le responsable
du service foresti le responsable du
secteur lissage des cheveux itou temaru
le résultat carbonisé tout le repas de
noël seul art ans a survécu
c'est super cool honteux pour rester en
enfance et pour se faire engueuler on ne
fut pas en rond